you're an active guy still you play a
lot of golf is that right
golf golf is about as active yes i i
i do uh i hike and i do pilates yeah
yeah yeah you shouldn't ever tell anyone
that
never guys should never say i do pilates
uh but were you golfing at you were
there pebble beach uh
i was just on pebble beach last week
didn't play that well but it's the best
fun
i have all year but you know you know
you get you're not as i'm older than you
but you know you get up there you gotta
move around and stay busy i found i
i found one advantage to getting older i
i was playing basketball as
a matter of fact with my son my son's on
his high school team so we were in the
backyard
and he gave me an elbow in the groin he
gave me a but
like a dead center like yeah yeah it
wasn't like a graze or anything it was
right there
right and every guy knows this hasn't
happened to me in like 20 years where i
had a bullseye shot there
and every i don't have to tell every guy
that's the worst worst pain
imaginable yeah so i get hit there it
wasn't as bad as i thought
no what what do you mean i
figured it out here's why when you're in
your 20s
things are just compact right
yes but now there's give there's
there's slack there's slack
so you take uh right yeah your
impact is spread over a greater area you
know what it is you take a punch but it
it's like punching a curtain
you can live you can survive
here's the thing when you're 20 you
don't want to get hit there because you
you use you yeah that's the body
saving the species it's warning you
don't get hit right but now
what do you really need what do you need
you know what they are
you know what they are now they're like
tonsils people
don't keep them uh i gotta ask you just
okay in your life
uh everybody loves raymond the show
syndicated such a big hit it's
everywhere
can you go i've known you
i've known you for a long time you're a
regular guy is it hard for you to go
anywhere and not be
recognized no it depends in la it's
pretty
pretty easy right like when you go out
get outside of the business area
i get hit a little bit up you know new
york i go back to new york and my
family's still in new york
right so i get hit up but it's you know
it's cool and people are other people
like sometimes you don't know does
someone want to be your friend because
they're they know you friends show
business or they want to be one thing is
when you have a tv show a lot of
you do get people who want to be your
your friend and
it's a good problem to have i can't be
friends with them right
because i don't have time but i tell you
what i've noticed now that i'm in my 50s
i will make the time to be someone's
friend if they're a doctor
if you're a doctor
i want to buddy up to anybody
here's what happens as you get older
i've found you gravitate towards certain
friends like
when you're 18 it's the kid with the car
the kid with the car is very popular
yeah you want to be his friend
when your 20s it's the kid who has
connections you know the kid who his
brother works at a strip club
you know he can get you you can get your
tickets to reo speedwagon
right it does that doesn't seem like
much but 30 years ago that was big
yeah yeah third back when things were
compact that was a plan yes
but 30s to 50s lawyers you want lawyer
friends
yes because you're gonna you're gonna
get divorced you gotta get a picture of
your dick off the internet something's
going to happen
50s to 70s you can't have enough doctor
friends yeah and the weird thing is in
the 80s
it's back to the kid with the car it
comes all the way around